[Musique]
ce dimanche 3 juin à la villa du
département s'est déroulée une soirée de
gala à l'occasion de la tenue dans notre
île entre le 14 mai et le 2 juin de deux
formations de lier hpd n le 107e cycle
jeunes et la 212e session en région qui
aura regroupé au total une centaine
d'auditeurs de la réunion mais aussi de
mayotte des comores de madagascar de
maurice edu mozon de nuit c'est des
métiers hors président du département a
félicité ces nouveaux auditeurs pour
leur investissement et leur dynamisme
tout au long de ces deux formations se
sont en fait des personnes qui
participent à la prise en compte des
opérations de défense et de sécurité et
donc il ya des sessions de formation qui
sont organisées par des généraux les
formateurs venus de métropole et ce qui
est important de souligner c'est que à
cette formation participe bien sûr
beaucoup de réunionnais mais aussi des
personnes venant des îles de l'océan
indien et même du mozambique madagascar
maurice les comores et l'ensemble de ces
personnes en fait participent à ces
sessions de formation et chaque année et
acheter en forme comme cela
donc plusieurs personnes lors de cette
soirée un vibrant hommage a été rendu au
général de fils alexandre lalanne baer
boutique chef du bureau des sessions en
région alliage edr et dont la sr de 112
marque la fin d'une longue carrière au
sein de cet institut relevant du premier
ministre et au cours de laquelle il aura
formé deux mille huit cents auditeurs
prémunissons donc en l'occurrence 55
auditeurs de tous les milieux civils et
militaires fonctionnaires et privés
et nous réfléchissons à toutes ces
questions nous leur donnons aussi un
aspect de formation avec trois pôles
c'est bien ensuite des visites où nous
allons voir les unités militaires qui
sont en sur place les certaines
installations industrielles
lorsqu'il y en as comme ça que nous
avons visités par exemple le grand
chantier de la route de la nouvelle
route du littoral
[Musique]